an achievement british swimming have put
on here in these olympic games they have
won so many medals they are now the most
successful team gb
swimmer team in all of history it is a
great performance this is what
adam petey and james guy two of the
stars with six medals around their necks
when we spoke to them earlier
this is what they told us about how
expectations expectations on that team
have just been driven higher and higher
it's just amazing to see that the
heritage
and the depth of british women has
developed so strongly over the last few
years
and now you've got a new generation
coming through learning from our
mistakes firstly but
making their own paths and when he went
the heat time semi-final time in the
final
and he got that gold which we knew he
was going to get for us it's kind of the
ball started rolling
and i think you know what i'm latched on
to that and duncan did
and tom dean did once that momentum was
carrying forward you know he started off
and i think
that's where it came from that's where
it's been come from since rio amongst
all those medals of course there's also
duncan scott who has got four around his
neck three silver and one gold
the most decorated gb athlete in one
olympic
games this is what he told us about his
experience out here in japan
my initial feeling is you know i'm just
delighted and with the way the week has
gone you know obviously i set myself
really high standards and i want to try
and compete against the best in the
world
and some races have gone you know better
than i anticipated and others certainly
not but um you know i have to come away
with a week you know i'm
really excited